whatever she says is irrelevant it's
irrelevant
what you're saying right now is
irrelevant james
i'm not going to want to be in the same
room as her
what you're chatting is irrelevant bro
you can't justify it you can't justify
it i'm sorry
[Music]
good comfy ready set
and we're off um guys
what's good chilling same
um guys this is it you know
we're still moving on with this
competition if you want in bro
patreon between now and when we hit a
thousand a month
this is it if you want to get entered
for the prize draw
of a t t tier four
month that's your own personalized merch
that's an hour
one to one conversation with me and fou
had just you and us bro
real intimate candles the lot
everything incense it says the works the
works trying to create ambiance
um yeah man
stereo sessions your own merch as i said
discount on our merch every tin man
um jump in and uh yeah let's let's let's
get this money so we can get two
episodes a week out for you guys
um obviously guys if you're watching
this on youtube
you have to like the video you have to
man you have to it's mandatory
if you don't like it then bro
what are you even doing what are you
doing um throw in a comment we love the
comment section
comment section stays busy always um and
guys
add us on the socials instagram twitter
it's all in the description
and um of course man
just jump on the merch jump in the
patreon
jump in the s g fam um
and yeah and that's how we go i mean
what i don't i don't know what else i
need to say this is a weekly week by
week
thing you should know this by now you
should mom
all right guys the ff for today is about
another guy
um his name is tsutomu yamaguchi he's a
japanese brother
so in 1945 he survived the first atomic
blast in hiroshima
despite being spun in the air like a
tornado and landing face first in a
ditch
after a quick after a quick recovery
he jumped in a train to nagasaki
arriving just in time for the second
bomb
he survived that one too and i'm gonna
give you more context
please do bro yeah yeah it sounds like
an x-man yeah
yeah i'm a gucci um lived and worked in
nagasaki but in the summer
of 1945 he was in the he was in
hiroshima for a three month long
business trip
on the 6th of august he was leaving the
city with two colleagues
and was on his way to the train station
when he realized he forgot he's hanko
a hanko is a type of identification
stamp common in japan
and returned to his workplace to get it
at 8 15 a.m
he was walking towards the docks when
when the american b-29 bomber and nola
gay
dropped the little boy atomic bomb near
the city
near the center of the city only three
kilometers away
so yamaguchi recalls seeing the bomber
and two small parachutes before that
before there was a great flash in the
sky
and he was blown over the explosion
ruptured his eardrums
blinded him temporarily and left him
with serious radiation burns over his
left side of the top half of his body
after recovering he crawled to a shelter
having rested he set out to find his
colleagues
they had all survived and spent the
night together in a night air red
shelter
shelter before returning to nagasaki the
next day
in nagasaki he received treatment for
his wounds
and despite being heavily bandaged had
reported to work on august the 9th
on the 11th on at 11 a.m on august the
9th
yamaguchi was describing the blast in
hiroshima to a supervisor
when the american bomber boxster dropped
a fatman atomic bomb over the city
his workplace again put him 3k from
below
from ground zero but this time he was
unhurt from the explosion however he was
able
he was unable to replace his now ruined
bandages
and he has suffered high fever and
continuous vomiting for over a week
so literally these two bombings happened
three days apart so
let me let me try and recap yeah pick me
up if i get everything wrong yeah yeah
i'm yamaguchi yeah i love that name yeah
i'm a gucci
so i'm just minding my business on a
general work day yeah
i'm trying to dip to nagasaki yeah but i
forgot my little
id yeah as i said it's in the office
yeah i go to dip back
as i'm walking across the street i see a
couple parachutes
and a bright light below it i said
what's that
before i can think straight bang i'm in
the s
spinning spinning spinning like a
tornado bro
spinning ladder in a ditch ear drums
burst i said jesus
i said jesus i said nani
nani nani a crew
yeah to a shelter find my boys
we all holed up in there for a couple of
days yeah it looks safe
meek acting man's just man it looks cool
yeah yeah i'm bandaged up and i finally
get to nagasaki yeah and i'm like
business as usual he cracks on he tries
to crack on tries to crack on i can't
afford to lose this job
on my way to work again i see that
again fool me once
bro full massive fool me once
again bang
again marked again
bandages astray all my wounds get
infected
i've got a fever and i'm vomiting for a
week again
i don't know why that sweet would be and
i'm just vomiting
for time and after that i said please no
more
no more bro and then no more
no more happened but and this happened
when he was
uh how old was he doesn't say 1945
but he died he actually died in 2009 i
know 2010 at the age of 93
oh wow from stomach cancer he survived
two bobbins and then cancer took him
cancer takes everyone cancer takes
everything
if i make it past 90 cancer needs to
allow me
like i'm i'm here you're not wanted here
yeah yeah i'm
suffering enough as it is yeah i'm not
yeah i need you bro
yeah i don't need cancer to to make it
up bro it's just
it's [ __ ] ridiculous
um yeah we don't need cancer
we're good yeah i can't get out of it
in the morning it's hard as it is man
stomach sounds horrific as well i can
imagine i don't know what a nice kind of
cancer is
but i don't think there is i had a
client one time years ago
his name was rob he had cancer on his
ear bro i didn't even know that
neither did i he had this horrible
little tumor
on his ear and it was jet black it
looked like it'd been burned by a
lighter
this bump on his ear it was jet black oh
wow man said if you
if you touch it like this worst pain
you've ever felt in your life how does
he like shower and
bro i don't know he's a trooper dress up
and yeah he was a trooper he's
he's he was a big guy i'm talking about
six
three over 300 pounds big like
overweight dude
but he's like he's strong bro okay like
he's thick
yeah like his calves are [ __ ] huge
yeah yeah like he used to play rugby
sure he's just like a big rugby guy who
got fat
basically yeah yeah he's a serious
[ __ ] guy yeah and um
yeah he had discounts on his ear man
said it's just unbearably painful
damn i can only in my exterior as well
yeah so yeah he said if you literally
get dressed anything if you knock it
sleep if you turn him to sleep if you
sleep he has to sleep once i wake up so
he said he woke up screaming
woke up in the night screaming just from
a little knock [ __ ]
man and then yeah one day he came in and
he had half his half a [ __ ] ear gone
and he said yeah they sorted it
literally took half his ear off yeah
they just
cut a [ __ ] huge hole in here and then
just sewed it together um
yeah mom was like we move that's it came
straight from the hospital to the gym i
was like let's do this
gang gang yeah yeah
he was a cool yamaguchi yeah yeah yeah
yeah i don't know what i've got on with
it yeah i wouldn't do well with cancer
man
i don't think i would in the slightest
i'm far too tired for um
chemo and that this whole vomiting and
all this nah bro
will darpy me i'm tired as it is fam
i'm convinced i've got iron deficiency
you probably do bro convince just take
iron there all right
[Music]
what are we talking about takes a
[ __ ] iron bro it's so
easy to find jesus
oh that's hilarious i used to take um
i used to take a lot of iron tablets
when i was on my old spot i don't take
them as much now
i don't have them i haven't bought them
since i've moved um but i don't feel
like they made a difference
really but then again i
might only be thinking that one because
it's been a long time since i've taken
them and two because i'm [ __ ] tired
now
you know so i don't know whether it made
a difference but i don't feel like it
did i
it says take one a day there are times
where i took at first i was taking one a
day every day for a while
and sometimes i took two but didn't feel
any different i still felt like i felt
tired when i was gonna feel tired you
know
so i don't know i don't know i think you
do you think
do you think you have an issue with your
sleep
more give me more contact so obviously
you sleep through
but you wake up [ __ ] tired every time
i've never known you to wake up
sprightly um
that's because every time you see me
for me to have the days off that we have
especially not nowadays
prior to um prior to us
doing it i think at the end of every
month once a month i think you should do
this priority
before then obviously i had to request
the days off
and if i'm requesting these days off
especially sunday and monday i have to
work at least
x amount of days in between and when we
used to record back in the day i used to
do breakfast shifts remember
and there are days where i had to do the
breakfast shift and then obviously you
come and meet me
and then now this is before we used to
go out before recording
before recording and and before pod
could be ever podcasted at all
when you come up and visit me and manny
you used to go out right and
i'd have to i'm always working on the
day either working on a day
that we we are going out or i've worked
the night before so i'm always tired the
day you come
granted always tired today i was gonna
cut you off
i'm talking about as long as i've known
you oh bro i'm always tired i can't
remember like back in the day exactly i
remember
back in the day when we first started
living together this would be the
routine
era would wake up first then i would
wake up me and him would go downstairs
and watch tv
about two hours after that you'd come
out of your room
with your flannel on your shoulder walk
up the stairs walking past and we'll be
like what's good bro
and you'd kiss your teeth and walk past
us
and go wash your face that's that's
that's how you've been as long as i've
known yeah you're being tired
so i'm wondering if you have like i
don't know maybe like a magnesium
deficiency or something
something that's stopping your rem sleep
like your deep deep sleep
from like nourishing you or am i wrong
do you find that if you have like a deep
deep do you wake up like
[ __ ] [ __ ] and then just get on only
after a few days
like if i've got two or three days off
like no let me not use furloughs as well
because
i wasn't don't i wasn't necessarily
tired during photo because i was doing
[ __ ] all
but um if i've got two days off back to
back
because of work and i'm not recording
i'm not doing anything i
of a doubt to be fair that as well as
long as i've known you you've been
someone who your sleeping pattern
your sleeping pattern's been all over
the place like from
bar work to [ __ ] dj in
to obviously hospitality hospitality
yeah man yeah to be fair you've always
been a night owl
so it's hard for me to balance
everything out
yeah fair play that makes sense then
yeah that's probably what it is i'm just
always tired bro always tired but i try
and
obviously make time for stuff that i
need to make time for but yeah of course
i'm just a knuckle no
yeah yeah of course you do um
i just need to prioritize my sleep and
my well-being
um i'm thinking now that
once i it's still going to take a few
more weeks to set in maybe even a few
more months but once
i'm i'm content with the fact
that i don't
work anymore yeah apart from this and a
couple of hours of pt here and there
i think i can finally be in the place of
my life where i prioritize my sleep
because in all my other jobs
i resented working so much
that i would stay awake as late as i
could
and have as little sleep as i could
because i'm like i'm gonna hate tomorrow
anyway yeah
so i may as well be tired and enjoy my
time not being at work
like i want to be awake for every minute
that i'm not at work because i [ __ ]
hate being at work so much
and i hated the concept of working all
day
having a [ __ ] time coming home making
dinner
going straight to bed and sleeping my
entire free time away
so i could wake up and go back to work
that's um sorry to cut you off i
completely completely completely get
that because obviously
um like you said i'm a night owl i do a
lot of like later shifts and long shifts
so when i do get home from work for
example if i do a
late on a friday or saturday if i'm
getting home or finishing work around
3am for example and i get home maybe
like 3 15 3 30.
i am more likely gonna obviously by that
point i'm ravenous
yeah i'm starving all i want to do is
shower and eat yeah yeah
so once i've done that i feel like okay
i just can't go straight to bed i need a
bit of me time yeah because the only
what i've been doing recently apart from
like the the days off that we are
podcasting
um all i do is go to work
come home eat shower have like two hours
to myself
sleep wake up and do the same thing
again
that's all i do so when i
i'm always tired because i'm sleeping so
late but the reason why i'm sleeping so
late is because i'm using
a few hours just to relax and have me
tired just be regardless of what time it
is
because i know i'm not going to get this
during the day tomorrow yeah 100 that's
how i've been for years
so i need uh bro it's uh it's an endless
cycle yeah vision that's why i said
if i've got two days off in a bounce
it's the second day that i feel okay
yeah yeah
because the first day i'm still a bit
hazy yeah yeah still a bit hazy you know
i'm still a bit like tomorrow for
example i know i'm going to feel okay
tomorrow evening
yeah because i've got two days off of
the bounce today and tomorrow and i feel
calm you know
okay so it's it's it happens sometimes
but i also don't like having two days
off in a row
in the same week because because then
you know you're gonna work work before
my next day off bro
ah it's a time why are you saying when i
used to work for david lloyd mm-hmm
sorry to go off that's my energy i
hated working in a rotor because my boss
always did that to me where she thinks
she's making my life easier but just
making it harder where like
if i for example say if i book three
days off
big man i've got annual leave yeah use
it
use it yeah give me my three days annual
leave
and then give me two days off as well
yeah you know what i mean yeah
but no she'll give me three days off
yeah
not using any annual leave because she's
doing me a favor mm-hmm
and then i'll be working for the next 13
days yeah yeah yeah yeah
i should obviously want those three days
off yeah big man i've got annual leave
cause
use it
use it i don't want to work for two
weeks straight
you're killing me you're physically
killing me
[Laughter]
i hated it bro that's literally been my
last two weeks
nah that's literally been my last nah
bro
i've worked when you said to me because
i told you on the phone um
that i was working non-stop i did nine
days straight then i'm doing seven days
straight
when you said to me man said i've had
one day off in 16
oh my god i use that bar for everyone in
the next day at work yeah i use that
buffer it's just to give context of what
i'm working yeah yeah yeah yeah one day
off in 16
your eyes would widen that's two weeks
yeah that's more than two that's more
than two weeks even one day off
no no fam get hr
in here now tribunal as we speak bro
no no no no no no no no no no not my boy
not my bin knackered back ah bro let's
get you out of it guys
guys mission 1k okay push us over the
line please
who had needs out he's not gonna make it
i'm i'm working you man
i'm working you man ah nah just to eat
nah pay a couple bills just for basic
human rights
nah it's not on uh this is my day off
yeah this is what your day off looks
like oh it's tough man work on work but
yeah
um you got me would you rather yeah bro
i have i was literally just about to
pull up
so wait there
okay
this is gross
do i want to do this gross one or do i
want to do
i think either one will still make a
good conversation
yeah let's just do the gross one now
[Music]
right someone sent this in
so your mum and your girlfriend have
swapped brains
and the only way you can smoke them back
is you have to smash one of them
which one are you treating me
well played with like well played that
is
that's well played that's class um i
think off the cuff i'd have to still
smash my girl in the physical body with
my mom's brain i can't even oh wow i
can't
i can't physically smash my mother's
body even though she's got my girl's
brain in it
that makes no difference to me i'm
looking at my mum
you know everything exterior is the same
yeah
it's just the brain that's different i
mean you make that face but who are you
choosing really
oh i know you're choosing the same one
as me i know but imagine bro
you're in it obviously it's your
girlfriend's body in that but your mom's
chat in a way she's not chatting away
she's moaning she's not moaning family
as she can't help bro not enough she
ain't been a young 20 something in a
minute shut the [ __ ] up not in a not in
a
sexy way but i'm gagging her
not in a sex way she can't moan she
can't we need to get this over with
james
how long do i need to penetrate you
you need to finish the break so the
brains can swap you need to finish
oh then i'm gagging and i'm i'm wishing
for luck
i'll have to do it i might flip her over
whichever way i can knock her
whichever
i mean it's still my girl's body oh
wow yeah looking at me and i'm and i'd
know it's my mum
ah nice i'll have to flip her over i
couldn't look her in the eye
i couldn't look her in the eye
[Laughter]
what would you choose let's do one's
gotta go
[Music]
what would you choose today would be
one's got to go because funnily enough
the one's gotta go is actually
leads on well from this what needs
unwell from this
what i'll answer the question then i'll
show you nah i'm not i'm joking i've got
way more before once i'll go
actually no we will if he leads on for
it we'll do one go and then we'll do the
rest of the things yeah we can mix it up
all right
yeah we can [ __ ] mix ups our show we
do we won
um yeah obviously i'm choosing the same
issue yeah
it's nasty though isn't it it's
disgusting bro
it's disgusting oh my days yeah that was
great i like that question
it's disgusting but then again you're
not picking the other one i'm not
picking the other one
i don't care i'm not picking that other
one but hear me out i'm not picking
everyone but
just imagine how obviously without
looking
just the way your girl in your mom's
brain will be able to
coach you through it no just before not
not not when you're naked or anything
like that
but just you know who you're talking to
but
it's my mom's body i know it's my mom's
face
whatever she says is irrelevant it's
irrelevant
what you're saying right now is
irrelevant james
i'm not going to want to be in the same
room as her
what you're chatting is irrelevant bro
you can't justify it you can't justify
it i'm sorry
i'm sorry if you want to pick that pick
yes ah bruv [ __ ] that hurt
that's what i used to say
i was waiting for this that's what i
used to say
before i discovered landscapes
and they're anti-nick technology bro
with their anti-nick technology bro
no more of that
bro with manscapes no more nooks and
cranny no no no more nicks bro no more
scratches
no more ouchies nothing smooth smooth to
the touch
baby bottom smooth bro just this thing
yeah dog yeah well best brains of your
life
guaranteed guaranteed money back
guarantee oh
god bro if you want the perfect
package bro with the weed whacker on the
side
you've got father's day round the corner
do pops a favor bro
give him the give him give him the nut
he deserves you get me
let him trim that let momsey see what
she's been missing for the last 30 years
yeah man should she too she wants to she
wants that
without having to yeah she doesn't want
a floss floss
she wants a hard-boiled egg she wants it
sliding out
uh son be a good daughter yeah mom yeah
man
um ladies help your man you know get
that as a gift
perfect gift perfect gift yeah man the
man's never gonna turn down he's never
gonna turn that down he needs it more
than he thinks
yeah yeah yeah yeah be sure oh man be
started with it don't say it
just supply the team supply it man guys
if you want to jump on
that is discount code s n g
you know the works 20 off and free
shipping manscape.com
code sng that's all we need to say let's
get on with the episode
i'm feeling good let's go right how are
you how are you
all right so this week's one's gotta go
is more of a
18 plus that's what i said it's stems
and sfw
no yeah exactly not safe for work so
that's why i said it stems on from what
you said on the
on the um
would you rather that's what i was
looking for okay i don't know more than
this
one's got to go 18 plus version come on
then missionary
oh okay cowgirl doggy
and the spooning that the spoon sex
spoons are
raided underrated or under i feel like
it
maybe i underrate it a lot then you're
not a fan it's i'm not
i'm not not a fan it's just that i don't
do it enough
for it to be in contention yeah i don't
i rarely do it but when i do it i get
into it the thing is i get too into it
there's not a spoon anymore
i get yeah cause i have to climb up like
i said yeah yeah
and then we're on the this team yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah the flat
flap the flat
flats at the back that's one of my
favorite i couldn't put that in there
yeah yeah flat to the back is my name i
know what that position is called but i
love it
um yeah yeah yeah yeah i stopped the
spoon thinking
um yeah but then i'm not good yeah i
want to get
right i'm just
that's me boy and then we end up going
flat to the back yeah yeah yeah
yeah so yeah to be fair um so missionary
cow
back shot and spoon in that sense
lock off the spoon yes yeah because i
just need more
yeah yeah
it's a starter though yeah yeah it's a
good thing it's a good starter
it's a good entry appetizer sorry yeah
appetizer actually small plate
cheeky for the table all right
finger in head so that's you
um giving head rather as opposed to
receiving um
titty sucking or kissing
one's gotta go finger and head did you
say it's me giving him you're giving
okay fingering your head given it's
fingering giving head
and lipson uh
oh tea tea suck gotta go yeah okay
why i love it but it's just there's no
way
it's not even the same yeah league
that's what i said same with the spoon
and it's not in it's not there yet yeah
yeah comparison spoon isn't there yet
for me all right cool
dirty talk spanking
choking and then spitting them out
uh and this is all drawing yeah yeah of
course obviously
you're not fully close standing and
staring at me no no i mean like dirty
talk is it i don't know if you might
over phone or whatever no no during
during this during interviews oh boy i
chat you said something i chat
i say whatever comes to mind
i'm chini waggy um that's staying
and that's all i know that's staying say
no more uh spanking
also other once again choking and
spitting him off
i think spanking can go you know why
because that was probably my foundation
level into the nasty nasty okay
you know what i mean yeah that's where
it started yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah for the first time
that one's where you're like you're
hugging or she's on top you just give it
a quick just
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah she's going for
it just to test the buoyancy yeah yeah
yeah
the ripple effect and then she gives it
a
look
[Music]
yeah so that could go because i've
played that out yeah i've played
spanking i've ruined batteries
yeah yeah so the rest is i'm still in it
say no more say no that's jokes okay all
right
this is all obviously all in terms of
the actual act of sex
so romantic sex a quickie
slow and deep or spontaneous sex one's
gotta go
run it again romantic yeah a quickie
yeah slow and deep
yeah spontaneous okay
do separate romance romantic and slowly
you're gonna say that
so romantic slumming deep you can you
can
slow and deep [ __ ] anyone but when i say
roman
romanticizing and romantic sex in terms
of
we're in love yeah it's your party like
you wouldn't do this with anyone else
kind of thing
lips you know just just nose to face to
hear
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah it doesn't
matter what you do to the room because
it's just you and her
okay that's why i'm not romantic whereas
slow and deep yes you could be [ __ ]
anyone but you can [ __ ] them slowing
[ __ ] them deep okay same way like you
[ __ ] anyone hard and fast you know
all right uh romantic
slowing deep uh what was the other ones
again sorry so romantic slow and deep
a quickie and spontaneous sex oh okay
love a quickie love spontaneity mm-hmm
and uh i think so deep can go okay that
romance
is a different thing it bro romance sex
is a difference yeah
yeah that's like a michelin star
restaurant
you hardly ever go but when you do oh
it's the best
yeah it's the one that once yeah yeah
yeah okay gang
this one is in terms of um licking slash
kissing
okay so this is to get done to you
um yeah so your neck getting licked
slash kiss
your nipples um your ears or your
nipples
i don't care what's left nipples get it
out
unless you've got my anus on there get
nipples out
don't go near them bro
ah talk to me why i've never i hate it
why i hate it not that it's not i'm not
even saying that because it's something
i love or don't love
but because i've never known that about
you
that i hate it yeah uh i don't know bro
it's just
it's always been the thing for me it
just tickles too much
i feel vulnerable i feel vulnerable bro
why um
i don't know how do i explain it
probably because
it's all right cool right so
if you're anywhere else that you're
targeting
is a specific erogenous zone
okay specific erogenous zone
now if your lips in my chest it's not an
erogenous zone
so you're not you're not after anything
you're not targeting anything
you're just lifting me all over that's
fine if you licked my stomach my chest
everything you're just lifting me in it
that's fine or licking me whatever
you're doing mm-hmm
but if you're going after zones i need
them to be zones
my neck is a zone my ear is a zone
my tall zone never had it but if my body
i'm aware as a zone
for me my nipples are not a zone but
she's going to treat them like they are
and she's going to look me in the eye
and give it one of them like i'm a
yeah like i'm a yeah
so it's more about is it more about what
you look like in the act of her licking
your nipples then
it's a combination of what i look like
yeah
how i feel about myself how i feel
what i look like how i feel yeah and the
mount it tickles
like my ear tickles but i'm i'm here for
it you know what i mean my ear tickles
but it's like
i'm aware that this is a thing for me
and i'm happy for you to go for it
this is just a tickly spot really it's
just a tickly spot for me
okay and it's just it's just like what
to me i don't know i'm looking i think
what are you doing
okay like i know that my nipples don't
feel the way
that she feels when i do hers i just
known
it for a fact 100 i don't know i don't
know i don't know i don't know
okay it's just not for me bro i
in that in that lineup i would say
nipples as well but not for the reasons
that you're saying it one i've never had
my nipples
like licked that many times in that
context obviously yes
when you say doing the chest and the
stomach maybe they might go there yeah
yeah i don't find it one my nipples
aren't that sensitive my earlobes on the
ananda and james
i've had my earlobes licked and it sends
shivers to my heel back
yeah same my ears are sensitive bro
the thing is my nipples aren't even
sensitive like right now like
nothing nothing nothing yeah but as soon
as someone's
targeting them specifically like if you
reached over and went like that on my
nipple
i would squeal i would squeal
and not in a good way bro that is
hilarious i don't know there's something
about
it okay just like if i scratch my foot
bottom it doesn't tickle
but if you went like that on my foot oh
my god i'd pass out
so yeah that's what the nipples are for
me
so the ones that i've got to go are in
20 second
spanking slow and deep sex and nipple
licking
yeah yeah that was fun good i like stuff
like that well done
that was a nice change um that's jokes
oh man okay cool i've got a little
question hit me
do you ever
i was thinking about kids the other day
and just how brutal they are
give me context so just how kids don't
have a filter and how honest okay
yes of course i completely agree and do
you ever remember as a kid like this is
not bullying or anything but just like
alienating a kid by a complete
accident or feeling alienated just by
someone's
unapologetic honesty
um
no but i do remember as a kid in primary
school i think i was probably in the
year
four or five um there was a guy in my
class
who he i wouldn't say we alien is but
okay there was like a little kick let's
say
it was kind of like i'll click for
example but in primary school
but there was a guy that wasn't in our
clique but he was just in our class
and he stunk
james
stunk yeah it just didn't make any sense
you know
it just didn't make and we all knew he
was going home and it was come back like
he just started he didn't make it yes
yeah was it a beer well i do do it was
more like b.o
slash his clothes just never got washed
yeah yeah yeah you know
yeah yeah and it just perplexed me
because
he obviously lives like he's he's five
he's got a house you know
he's got somewhere to do his laundry
yeah yeah yeah
so it just baffled me and it was one of
them ones where i
i didn't like speak anything bad towards
him or in front of him
but i just didn't entertain him you know
so i feel like that's the only way i
kind of alienated someone
but not in the way you said it you know
when you said that
or when you started saying it that's the
first thing that came to my head swear
down yeah yeah mine was two i've got two
story times okay
hit me bro one of me alienating someone
and the other woman me getting alienated
cool so the first one was me alienating
so do you ever remember playing kiss
chase
yeah bro yeah right so i remember being
in primary school one time right yeah
and it was all the kids chasing and i
fancied all the girls we were playing
with
yeah bar one uh daisy yeah
yeah daisy bro yeah daisy
to paint a picture in my head
i must have been like year four year
five in my head she was six
three
long limbed yeah athletic yeah
black ting yeah tightest camera you've
ever seen yeah
and she had you know the white mouth
corner
yeah she had bag of that yeah just bare
white old spit in her mouth corner
ashes knuckles she looked like a street
fighter
i didn't know does she fancy me or
anything like that yeah
[Music]
but we all organized the game a kiss
chase yeah
and everything's going whenever the girl
so is the girl's turn the boys are done
their time
is the girl's turn so the girls need
like all boys are running around et
cetera et cetera
and then one girl bro
i'm vex basically none of the paintings
are chasing me
sam went didn't chase me she chased tom
megan
didn't chase me chase rhys they all got
their hands on the man they wanted in
there yeah
and all the guys were kicking yeah just
bear happy
yeah and i'm just running slow fast yeah
you're waiting like
he's just jogging around like catch me
yeah he can't crush me
don't catch me no one wanted it
charlotte no one bro
yeah and then daisy's turn rock on
i'm just standing around at this point
when i say i'm done running bro yeah
and daisy like she ain't lips at me
that's for damn sure
i'm chilling i'm not even paying
attention
i'm not even paying attention yeah and
i'm chilling
staring up in the sky waiting for daisy
to catch whoever she's going to catch
fam i look down
she's steam training towards me
like arms swinging fam straight ahead in
me
darting towards me when i say
fam i faked right and dick
she scared past my arm and like my hand
touched the floor
everything i scored i couldn't let this
hoe catch me bro
i couldn't and i'm running she's still
laughing but
i'm scared yeah yeah yeah i'm running
you're being chased by a
[ __ ] dog yeah yeah to the point where
i took my i had my rucksack on
the armor just swung it on the floor and
just dipped
bro dipped did and she's
fast alright six three fast
daisy's on my trail yeah yeah
and the little the little grit is flying
off the back of my shoes like i'm
running running running running
i must have tried to fake left again and
turn my foot slipped
and i landed straight in my back she
thought she had me up bro
she went to grab me and i swear to god i
did the
you know like the the kung fu [ __ ]
barrel roll like feet in the stomach oh
yeah yeah i did that
i did that i didn't know what else to
[ __ ] do i used to use my little
brother all the time
she came for man before she was gonna
mount me
and lips me up fam i grabbed her hand
feet in her stomach and flipped her back
on concrete on concrete and it didn't
hurt her
but when i say she was [ __ ] crying
bro
and she wasn't hurt [ __ ] crying fam
and i'm still like in my head i'm like
thank god
yeah i just survived a bear attack i
just survived a [ __ ] life-threatening
experience yeah
and all the girls came rushing over to
daisy like what's wrong what's wrong
and she was like oh jones thinks i'm
ugly he doesn't want me to kiss him
and i'm like to the man's like close
call were like
[Laughter]
flipping things i'm spotting the dance
like close
close call this thing i was scared
and i had no idea at the time of like
just the emotional impact i put on this
girl that i
clearly thought she was so hideous yeah
i would rather fling her on the floor
then let her catch me in a game of kiss
chase until
all the yes was like james you're
[ __ ] horrible you're [ __ ] horrible
why don't you just let daisy catch you
and i'm like big i know catch me you mad
yeah yeah yeah and only after that was i
like oh you're gay enough that hurts
people's feelings yes
yeah we don't let people know that we
find them repulsive yeah oh my god
you take the l and be a gentleman yeah
apparently apparently that's what you do
and that's the first time i realized
that ah actually with my honesty
alienate someone
and made them feel like [ __ ] when in
adult life you would never in a million
years ago
yeah of course course course um and i
didn't think i was doing anything wrong
i had no idea doing anything wrong um
so that's the first one that's when i
alienate somewhere that's how i
can't wait for the time i got alienated
yeah
was i was doing a ting i was in year
five again i think all year six
i was doing a ting with one yak called
sam
how do you remember same sound from
kisschase you didn't chase me yes
yeah she was out chasing tom [ __ ]
hugh one of these white guys
yeah yeah so she wrote me a note
one time do you like me yes no maybe
take the box bam my heart raced when i
got it what are these ones
yeah one of them things opened it up do
you like me
yes no maybe from sam yeah i said
swear my son i nudged my boy
scott next to me scott he had [ __ ]
blonde bright blonde curtains
white scott yeah nice to him i said fan
read this man's jaw dropped
jaw dropped because sam was a little
spicy spicy
she started wearing skirts before they
were allowed
okay yeah yeah okay yeah i didn't know
what i
was supposed to like about it yeah but i
just knew i was supposed to yeah so i
did
um so i took the yes twice that bang
sent it back she's like gang and then
sending another one back do you want to
go out with me
and i'm like yes ma'am ticked it so
we're ting we're together
on paper on paper we're literally okay
with your paper we didn't have
any conversation after that we were just
together yeah
um so i'm living my life
feeling good good next thing this must
be like two weeks later
she rolls across the playground holding
next don's hand
his name is muhammad i remember his name
was muhammad ali and i remember at the
time thinking that doesn't
even make sense
that's what i thought back in the day my
name was muhammad ali alaska kid
what are you all about your parents are
begging it didn't know anything about
muslim culture your parents are
begging you anyway yeah so she's holding
hands with muhammad yeah and i'm like
and muhammad was mixed race as well yeah
i'm like yo what's going on what's going
on
so they roll over to the field while i'm
chilling with my
my boys playing beyblades yeah
and she whispers sighting to muhammad
he lets go of her hand walks over to me
standing over me i remember the sun was
here and his head was blocking it you
know when you can't see their face
properly yeah yeah but he just blocked
out the sun to look over at me yeah our
man said ah sam told me to
tell me tell you that she's dumping you
and she's going out with me
heartbroken in front of the mandom oh in
front of everyone
and i said nah but i couldn't confront
her i was too nervous she was like
three paces back she'd say [ __ ] yeah i
said now
what and she i said why
[Music]
i said why man said
she wants her this is how you know
playground politics will peak
yeah she knew nothing about me bro yeah
but she said
she wants a boyfriend who can protect
her
and i can protect her better than you i
should
piss off that's the first word i left i
said piss off yeah no you can't yeah
man said ah he jumped on me from he
jumped on me bro
and we were wrestling yeah but he had
high ground
yeah yeah so i didn't stand a chance
from the word go i wasn't prepared yeah
he got on top of me
my hands were pinned all my [ __ ] was
tore up
yeah like my [ __ ] powder shirt was
draped out
my jumper everything a man man held me
down for five seconds
and said see and then got off
what they walked off into the distance
bro the mandem were just there
just and i was like
why on earth has that just happened but
i just assumed that's just
playground etiquette yeah i just thought
that's how relationships go yeah
i don't know anything better was this
before or after the kiss chase
i have no idea probably before oh no
probably after because i think it's
ironic that
um she tried to mount you and you
[ __ ] flipped her
and then mohammed came over you had no
choice
he married you i didn't know which one
was up sam that is
real life karma real life bro it was
probably
it was probably after the kiss chase i
literally can't remember i don't even
remember if it was the same year
i'm assuming it was but i had no [ __ ]
idea that's a letter but
bro oh when my homie walked off of my
girlfriend
man said my girl you didn't speak to her
at all oh of course but i just thought
that's what happened
she's my girlfriend but we don't speak
yeah there's nothing to talk about i
still chew my boys and stitches with her
girls like whatever
yeah man i said she wanted a man who can
protect her yeah and then live
year five showed me up in front of my
boys just left me there in the mud
in the mud school uniform all [ __ ] up
just so my mom could smack me about when
i get home as well
oh no i hated that when you got the gums
down
the knees my dad sparked me
i think i've thought on here before my
dad sparked me one day i had a draw
of gums that i couldn't wear to school
you've never told this story
um i i really think i have um the
drawing goes i could never wear to
school because it was like nicer gums i
think i wore a polo er oh you have
something you
mastered their certain yeah yeah yeah we
had art that day
oh i ruined that top ruined that top and
when i got into the yard
my kitchen was on the same so it's
um front door kitchen's here and like
the laundry room is there so i have to
pass the kitchen
to go to the laundry room to drop my
ship my dad was in he was in the kitchen
but i thought i was quick i darted in
took my top off put in laundry basket i
had a vest underneath
trying to run upstairs yeah he caught me
on the way back he's like where's the
shirt you wore to school
my mistake was going forward to the
laundry room to show him and he was
behind me so i was cornered
i should have said i was in a laundry
basket
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah so i'm walking now
i'm walking i'm walking to the lord room
and the laundry room
the door leads to the garden so that's
the exit
but he was in the doorway of me leaving
the laundry room the other way
so there's the two doors in there right
so i'm trapped in the middle he
go reaches for the basket picks up the
shirt sees it
clots me from nah
[Laughter]
i actually saw stars that day nah i
would never forget
i actually saw stars that day
i couldn't believe what was happening
yeah yeah yeah
i couldn't because of a shirt you know
nah bro sometimes these men take it too
far too far
too far too far but it's it's one of
them ones where you know you're never
going to do that again
i'll wash it and you can keep it because
clearly you don't want me to wear that
yeah 100
he climbed me that day ah yeah i
am my mum never really smell my dad
i remember that smacking me up like once
in my life
but he was more about the fear yeah i
remember you telling me
yeah with his voice the fear the bass
it was so scary that if the hand touched
you he could have gone like that i would
be like
i thought i would as i was dying yeah
just from how scared i was
so he never really did my mom did it so
much that i just learned to tolerate
i just learned to tolerate it to the
point where i would edgar on
do you remember the moment where
you gained control obviously well not
obviously um
where you gain control of your mum
trying to like beat you or whatever you
be like
they say wow remember i remember what
happened yeah she smacked me in the back
of my knee
mm-hmm like six times like what what
what whack and you know when you do the
nervous laugh
yeah i was like it doesn't even hurt it
doesn't even hurt i was vexed bro
you know i didn't even hurt i just you
know when you're so angry like say you
just got in beef like on road yeah yeah
and you just repeat yourself
yeah and i was like it doesn't even hurt
it doesn't even hurt
it doesn't it doesn't even hurt yeah it
doesn't
for no reason just so vet she would have
stabbed she would have
oh oh bro she did want to [ __ ] stab
me
she went for me it hit me here i ran off
ran up the stairs and i was thinking
i've got pace now as well
you can't even keep up with me and that
doesn't even hurt she was arming the
[ __ ] dad that's
i remember that's what she was saying
her voice dropped
i'm ringing your [ __ ] dad i've never
been so scared of my life
i've never that's a woman's threat a
mother's threat
because i'm going to tell you that yeah
that's the only way to get rid of
the final card i'm ringing your dad and
i
i'd given her so much chest yeah
that my pride would not let me say don't
do it yeah yeah yeah yeah [ __ ] ring
him then
yeah i mean i didn't say that i was too
scared to do that yeah but i was like
whatever i think i'll just say whatever
okay yeah and just went up to my room
and i remember my dad came
because he still lived in the same town
as me then my dad came and i thought i
was
the [ __ ] billy big dick yeah i was
laying on my bed
playing with a basketball a little
little toy when i was flicking it
and he was like what's going on and i
was like i don't know and i just kept
playing
man said put the ball down deepest voice
you've ever heard
the ball smack me in my face and i
started
shaking for ya i stopped shaking
i've never been so scared
fathers know how to inflict or instill
fearing kids
fear i've never been so scared in my
life bro
that's hilarious i don't even remember
what happened next and he didn't hit me
that time
but i just remember thinking i'm gonna
die
yeah yeah yeah this is not my dad this
is a guy this is the punisher i don't
know who this is bro
he's here to kill me yeah that's yeah i
remember that
[ __ ] that was scary the thing with my
parents is my dad
obviously he's a my dad obviously used
to beat me more than my mum
or obviously they were harder than my
mom's beats but my mum would
over exert it so let's say i'm getting
punished by my dad
for about five ten minutes my mom will
do a thirty just to prove a point
you know yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah so
jarring
my mom will punish me for time just to
prove a point
because she knows they've got when we
got to a stage of me being
physically stronger than her she would
punish me for a lot longer just to make
touch to remind
me that i'm her son wow but my dad
my dad could do one of them i would fan
i would body pop i don't think you
understand
i would body pop
but that used to fake backhand me
sometimes ah if i'm reading i'm
darsh i'm dashing the book i'm
protecting myself at all costs bro
oh i hated my parents yeah it was long i
remember being in trouble when my
dad first got my stepmom i was a
teenager but she questioned his
authority as a jokey joke one time
okay and i think she learned on the spot
don't ever do that again okay
not even in a threatening way okay but
my dad always i think i might have
studied before
we were at a theme park me and my
brother were just like [ __ ]
roughhousing or whatever yeah just
[ __ ] around in the queue and my dad
said behave
he always used to just say hey that's it
all he ever said one word yeah yeah
no stop no whatever didn't call anyone
by their names
behave yeah and you just stop yeah one
time we're [ __ ] around
my dad said behave so we stopped
and she said behave you didn't tell what
behave good or behave bad
and she's looking to she's trying to be
fun fun right now she's trying to build
bridges
she said fun like behave well good or
bad and she looked at us like huh
we weren't laughing you know you don't
play that you did
you don't know what time it is bro my
dad didn't say a word just looked at her
i've never seen him do her to an adult
before my mom just looked at her
she didn't know what to do yeah she
didn't know what to do she's never seen
this side
i didn't know she was scared or horny
but ah she didn't know
what to do she was probably both oh
probably both she was probably yeah
she fought swears so is this is it the
control you've got
yeah is this the control you've got this
is resolved
oh yeah yeah she was definitely all
clacking a little bit she was holding
she was scared
but she couldn't let the use know she
was scared this is the public she's in
the queue
yeah she must have been dripping bro
yeah it was long
it was like my dad didn't play um but
yeah
we've just got one fan request yeah man
gang let's do it and we're gonna wrap it
up this one's super interesting
gang right so
someone sent this in to us and she said
i heard about something really
interesting the other day and i think it
would be cool to hear you guys opinion
on it
there's this psychological complex
called the madonna [ __ ] complex
it's basically the theory that men are
unable to maintain
sexual arousal in committed
relationships and that men see women
as either the madonna which is like a
pure virgin who they want relationships
with or the [ __ ]
who they only want to have sex with i'm
pretty sure it comes from the idea that
men are attracted to relationships
with women who remind them of their
mother since that's where we form
our first relationships and therefore
don't desire them sexually
which could be why a lot of men cheat
with the [ __ ]
and still stay in their relationships it
was so mad to think about i just wonder
what you guys
if you guys could relate um love the
podcast it makes me piss myself so funny
do you know what's crazy about that
question yeah um i was talking to with a
couple of girls
not too long i think a few weeks ago and
we were talking about monogamy
okay and we were talking about how i
think we me you're spoken about this
before i don't know if you spoke about
this on a podcast but how
obviously monogamy is just a made-up
thing like it's a man-made thing yeah
and how we have just been
forced into this construct of believing
and assuming that
monogamy is the way of life that one man
should be one woman and vice versa one
or one b
it should be of one being should i let
me say rather you know and
i i can somewhat understand
the this ladies it was a lady yeah this
lady's question about the was it
mcdonough complex kind of thing
because not necessarily do i
think or see a relationship with someone
and then i
envision or think about my mother kind
of thing because i don't even know what
my relationship was like with my mother
when i was a kid because i can't
remember
you know but i can understand the idea
of the question
so there i've been in situations where
i've been with females or
in the past and i've either wanted more
we can see that it's not just sex it's a
bit more
but there is something missing
hence why she was talking about guys she
at all guys going going elsewhere
and they just want that girl as a [ __ ]
kind of thing
whereas this person gives you everything
you need
as a mother kind of should you know
gives you everything you need
but there's something missing bro and
it's the horror aspect
and it's not because of the fact that i
envisioned her as
like she said like a mum or whatever
like a virgin madonna
it's not because of that it's just
because sometimes i feel like
it's hard i'm okay i'm only speaking as
a man as opposed to speaking for people
because i'm a man
um i just don't sometimes see how it's
possible for monogamy to exist sometimes
because purely because of the fact that
we live in a day and age where one
social media
runs the world and it's easy for
guys girls whatever to find and see
attractive people
any and everywhere you go nowadays and
you can't
deny a fact you can't deny the fact that
someone is attracted
because if you look at them you think
they're attractive you can't help that
you know yeah yeah
so i don't see i don't think
i have this madonna [ __ ] complex
but i can understand why people do and
why people may
yeah if that makes sense i mean i've
definitely had relationships in the past
where
kind of yeah the mother thing i'm not so
sure about
but i feel like there's definitely
a time where you can be in a
relationship
with someone because at the end of the
day it's impossible it's impossible to
for you to see things as two
you're either one thing or the other so
you can see
like let's say if you took your girl for
example
you can be in a situation in your life
where you see her
as the virgin wife whatever
but if things played out differently and
that's when she's your girlfriend or
whatever
but if things played out differently you
met her all over again you could still
see that same person
as like the whole archetype whatever you
want to call it
um so it's not necessarily based down to
their personality or anything about them
it's kind of just what you're looking
for at that time
and then later on down the line they
could be they could become
either one of those things yeah yeah
that makes sense but sometimes i'm not
entirely keyed up on this theory and i
can't necessarily relate it to my life
but a lot of the time it's like
you know on the whole lady in the street
freaking the sheets too it's like
yeah you kind of want that like oh yeah
perfect woman is like lady street
freaking
sheets but it's like yeah but she also
can't
be both do you know what i mean like
sometimes there's certain things
that you don't want from your wife
and it doesn't mean obviously i know you
said about there's some
certain things missing for me i don't
think i've ever been in a situation
where i'm like ah something's missing
like from my wife i wish my wife or
something else
or there's something missing i want
something else it's more a case of
i don't want i don't want my wife to be
bonnie rotten
and that's okay you know what i mean
yeah yeah yeah i don't
want my wife to be bonnie rotten yeah if
you don't know who i'm talking about
google bonnie rotten yeah
i don't want that and that's oh that's
not a negative
thing yeah that doesn't mean i find my
wife any less attractive yeah it doesn't
mean i want to have any less sex with my
wife
it doesn't mean i want to cheat on my
wife but
different time different place if bonnie
rotten rocks up
you boy me
that's right you know in different
circumstances
single ready to mingle yeah a cheeky
bonnie rotten rolls up yeah i may not
say no
yeah and that's also okay yeah yeah yeah
yeah
but you also can't
have your wife you can't also look at
your wife the mother of your kids
and think oh yes it's filthy you know
what
you just can't and that's okay
this [ __ ] is filthy you know what i
mean
yeah yeah yeah when you play that way
yeah you just can't
and obviously i don't know how well that
correlates to this madonna hall complex
and like the deep psychological aspects
of it but i
would agree that there is definitely a
distinction
between a nasty [ __ ] that you may just
want to run into
in the streets of tallahassee yeah and
never think about again yeah and
actually your wife who you love
and it's a missionary lipstick or it's a
spoon to flat back
smash thing or it's all kinds of
different
facets of love and sex and all these
different things that you can explore
with
and there's just something a nasty step
over thing
where you just ruin there's fluids
everywhere and you're just like
yeah but you needed it yeah yeah and you
just want to shower yeah
it's a good relief yeah yeah be done
with it and just be done with it
it's like my week yeah like it's just
like having a wank yeah
yeah i mean yeah it's like having a
wedding yeah and just like
shameful yeah and you get on with your
day yeah
yeah and you're never gonna have both in
one person of course
is it physically impossible and i
sometimes i think women should stop
trying to be both just be who you are if
you're your guy's wife
don't worry about nasty skanks on the
street because it's not a competition
do i mean it's just not a competition
guys are going to cheat whether guys are
going to cheat
and they're not going to cheat if
they're not going to cheat it's not
about like oh guys want this and guys
want that
and if you don't want your man to cheat
then you need to be this no
none of that matters no none of that
matters there's just going to be an
occasion
where a certain guy is in a certain
situation and he makes an
adult decision that he's gonna do
something or he's not gonna do it
that has nothing to do with oh man he he
wants this type of girl or
maybe you're not giving him this in bed
and that and stuff it's just like bro
there's a [ __ ] people are
dominatrixes for a reason
they're cert and like you know i mean
like there's certain things and certain
weird kinks
that a guy might be into or a girl might
be into that they
just don't even even if their partner is
ready and
willing they just don't want it yeah do
i mean
they just don't want that i wouldn't
want that from their wife or their
husband
i was if if i'm obviously not but if
i was on to pissing in girls faces you
best believe i don't want to piss on my
wife's face yeah for sure
for sure yeah that's not doesn't mean
there's anything wrong with her yeah it
doesn't mean i'm not sexually attracted
to her
it's just i just don't want that yeah i
want that
from oscar the [ __ ] yeah i mean i want
that in hell
yeah and i just want to wash my sins and
get back to my happy life
um but yeah
it's like i don't know i don't
necessarily think it's a cheating thing
either because
you can be sexually starved
and still never cheat and you can be
completely sexually satisfied
and always always cheat yeah so i mean
of course
i've cheated in the past and it's never
because i've been looking for something
else
it's never because oh my wife's too good
and i need
this it's just circumstantial yeah i'm
just doing it because
i was i was an adult who wanted to be an
[ __ ] i didn't want to be an [ __ ]
but i wanted to be a selfish kid
and do what i want and i did it had
nothing to do with the other person
it's just i don't think yeah i'm not
sure that madonna sought and certain
complex
but on the whole complex necessarily
can be a justification as to why men
cheat yeah i hear you
and also women cheat just as much as men
even more yeah
tactically they oh yeah tactical
tactically yeah they're
they're pep guardiolas of cheating
that's neither here nor there
yeah but i would love to hear other guys
opinions if they're interested and
throw me in a dm and um or acid and
whatever
and i'd love to hear people's opinions
and ladies opinions
and yeah hit the comments and see um
[Music]
see uh see what it's saying
because i'm intrigued because i do often
hear a lot
especially like on a woman a woman
saying oh like
there's all this like talk about a guy
who wants this and a guy wants that if
you want to keep your man satisfied you
need to do this and you need to do that
and it's like yeah but not always but
there's
there's just certain roles you're never
going to be able to feel and you just
need to be cool with that yeah
you actually just need to be my girl
might
might want to [ __ ] a road man one time
mm-hmm true
a lot of girls i can wear as many
do-rags as i can find bro
but i'm never gonna be that guy
it's just it is what it is and i'm happy
to accept that i need to see you in a
drag james are you done
i need to don't you told me about this
before i need to see you wrong
you don't i do please
i'll just look if i wear a door right
i'd look like i'm supposed to be holding
the inside of someone's pocket in the
prison yard
do you know what i mean i look like
someone's pet hold it up
there wife beat her yeah [ __ ] my
sleeves are tied around my waist
and i'm holding someone's pocket
yeah i'm their little snap on their
little
backyard snack that's jokes that's jokes
but um yeah man another good episode in
the back hopefully i enjoyed that
question maybe
maybe answer the question yeah yeah
really kind of like yeah
yeah yeah yeah sometimes we do that
quite a bit yeah we do i don't know i
don't know
sometimes i don't like to be like nah
yeah and some like oh yeah
because that was a complicated one
because it's like i know where you're
coming from
but they said there's so many different
examples of it being wrong and there's
so many different examples of being
right that's just like i don't even have
an answer yeah it's kind of open and not
is it open-ended i don't know yeah but
we'll see um hopefully that can answer
the question
but if it didn't i'm sorry um but it is
what it is i guess that's
what it is bro we'll try again next week
yeah we'll see you next week guys hope
you enjoyed
and don't forget to like comment
subscribe if you haven't and share
guys
[Music]